The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOSHUA TENENBAUM: So
we saw in Laura's talk
this introduction to both this
idea of the child as scientist,
all the different ways that
children's learning seems
to follow the many different
practices that scientists use
to learn about the world,
not just the data analysis,
in a sense.
As much as various kinds of
statistics on a grand scale,
whether it's Hebbian
learning or backprop
important for learning, we
know that that's not all
that children do, just like
analyzing patterns of data
is not all that scientists do.
And then Laura added this
other cool dimension,
thinking about the costs
and rewards of information,
when is it worth it or not.
And you could say, maybe she
was suggesting that we should
develop the metaphor, expand
it a little bit from child
as scientist to maybe like the
child as-- oh, oops, sorry--
lab PI or maybe even
NSF center director.
Because as everyone
knows, but Tommy certainly
can tell you, whether you're a
lab PI who's just gotten tenure
or the director
of an NSF Center,
you have to make hard-nosed
pragmatic decisions
about what is achievable
given the costs
and which research
questions are really worth
going after and devoting your
time and other resources to.
And that's a very
important part of science.
And it's an important part
of intuitive knowledge.
I want to add another
practical dimension
to things, a way of
bringing out, fleshing out
this idea of the
child as scientist.
You can think about all
these, these are metaphors.
But they're things
that we can formalize.
And if our goal is to make
computational models of
and ultimately to get some
kind of theoretical handle on,
then these are helping us.
By adding in the
costs and benefits,
you bring in utility calculus.
And there's not just
naive utility calculus,
there's a formal
mathematical utility calculus
of these kinds of decisions.
Julian Jara-Ettinger,
who Laura mentioned,
was driving a lot of the work
towards the end of the talk,
has done some really
interesting actual mathematical
computational models
of these issues,
as has [? Choi ?] and the other
students you talked about.
So the direction I
want to push here
is what you might call
the child as hacker.
This is trying to make
the connection back
to this idea of formalizing
common sense knowledge
and intuitive theories as
probabilistic programs.
Or just more generally,
the idea of a program--
a structured
algorithm and a dat--
or some combination
of algorithms,
data structures,
networks of functions
that can scribe interesting
causal processes in the world,
like, for example
your intuitive physics
or your intuitive psychology.
That's an idea that we
talked a lot about last week
or whenever it was, earlier
in the week or last week.
And this idea that
if your knowledge is
something like a program, or a
set of programs, that you can,
say, for example, run
forward to simulate physics,
like we had last
time, then learning
has to be something like
building a program or hacking.
And I think you could make--
this is, again, a research
program that I wish I had.
Like Laura talked to the
end about the research
she wished she had.
It's not really
just a wish for her.
She actually is working
towards that research program.
And this isn't just
an empty wish either.
It's something that
we're working on,
which is to try to take--
just as Laura had
that wonderful list
of all the things scientists
do in their practices
to learn about
the world, I think
you could make a similar
list of all the things
that you do in your
programming or hacking.
By hacking I don't mean like
breaking into a secure system,
but modifying your code
to make it more awesome.
And I use awesome
very deliberately,
because awesome is a
multi-dimensional term.
It's just awesome.
But it could be faster, more
accurate, more efficient,
more elegant, more
generalizable,
more easily communicated
to other people,
more easily modularly
combined with other code
to do something
even more awesome.
I think there's a
deep sense in which
that aesthetic behind hacking
and making awesome code,
in both an individual and
a social setting, that's
a really powerful way
to think about many
of the cognitive
activities behind learning.
And it goes together with the
idea of the child as scientist
if the form of your,
quote, "intuitive science"
are computer programs or
something like programs.
So we've been working
on a few projects
where we've been trying
to capture this idea
and to say, well, what
would it mean to describe
computationally this idea of
learning as either synthesizing
programs, or modifying
programs, or making more
awesome programs in your mind.
And I'll just show you
a few examples of this.
I'll show you our good, our
successful case studies,
places where we've
made this idea work.
But the bottom line
to foreshadow it
is that this is
really, really hard.
And to get it to work for
the kinds of knowledge
that, say, Laura
was talking about
or that Liz was talking
about, the real stuff
of children's knowledge,
is still very, very open.
And we want to,
basically, build up
to engaging why that
problem is so hard.
From this to what Tomer and
then Laura will talk about later
on in the afternoon.
But here's a few at least
early success stories
that we've worked on.
One goes back to this idea
that I presented in my lectures
last week.
And it connects to,
again, something
that Laura was saying.
Here, a very basic
kind of learning.
It's just the
problem of learning
some generalizable concepts at
all from very sparse evidence.
Like one-shot learning--
again, something you
heard from Tommy, a number
of the other speakers.
We've all been trying to
wrap our heads around this.
How can you learn,
say, any concept
at all from very,
very little data,
maybe just one or
a few examples.
So you saw this kind
of thing last time.
And I briefly
mentioned how we had
tried to capture this problem
as something like this
by building this tree
structured hypothesis space.
And you could think of this as
a kind of program induction.
If you think that
there's something
like an evolutionary program
which generated these objects,
and you're trying to find
the sub procedure of it
that generated just
these kinds of objects.
But that's not at all how
we were able to model this.
We had a much simpler model.
But let me show you briefly some
work that we did in our group
a couple of years ago.
It's really just getting
out into publication now.
This is work that was
mostly done by two people--
Ruslan Salakhutdinov, who is
now a professor at Toronto,
although about to move
to Carnegie Mellon,
I think, and Brenden Lake.
He's a machine learning
person, also very well known
for deep learning.
And then Brenden Lake--
this is really mostly
what I'll talk about
is Brenden Lake's work,
who is now a post-doc at NYU.
And again, where we think
we're building up to
is trying to learn
something like the program
of an intuitive physics
or intuitive psychology.
But here we're just talking
about learning object concepts.
And we've been doing
this work with a data
set of handwritten characters,
the ones you see on the right
here.
I'll just put it up in
contrast or by comparison
to, say, this other much
more famous data set
of handwritten characters,
the MNIST data set.
How many people have seen
the MNIST data set, maybe
in some of the previous talks?
How many people have
actually used it?
Yeah, it's a great
data set to use.
It's driven a lot of basic
machine learning research,
including deep learning.
Yann LeCun originally
collected this data
set and put this out there.
And Geoffrey Hinton did
most of the development.
The stuff that now wins
object recognition challenges
was done on this data set.
But not only that.
Also a lot of Bayesian
stuff and probabilistic
generative models.
Now, the thing
about that data set,
though, is it has a very
small number of classes, just
the digits 0 through 9, and
a huge number of examples,
roughly 10,000
examples in each class
or maybe 6,000 examples,
something like that.
But we wanted to
construct a data set
which was similar in some ways
in its complexity and scale,
but where we had many, many
more concepts and, perhaps, many
fewer examples.
So here we got people to
write by hand characters in 50
different alphabets.
And it's a really cool data set.
So that total data set
has 1,623 concepts drawn.
You could call them
handwritten characters.
You could just call them
simple visual concepts
as a sort of a warm
up for bigger problems
of, say, natural objects.
And there's 20
examples per class.
So there's roughly
30,000 total data points
in this data set,
very much like MNIST.
You can see, just
to illustrate here,
there's many different alphabets
that have very different forms.
You can see both the
similarities and differences
between alphabets here.
So in that sense, there's kind
of a hierarchical structure.
Each one of these is a
character in an alphabet.
But there's also the
higher level concept
of a sort of a Sanskrit
form, as distinct
from, say, to Gaelic,
or Hebrew, or Braille.
There's some made-up alphabet.
But one of the neat
things about this domain
is that you can make
up new concepts,
and you can make up whole
concepts of concepts,
like whole new alphabets.
You can do one-shot
learning in it.
So let's just try this
out here for a second.
You remember the tufa demo.
We can do the same
kind of thing here.
Like let's take
these characters.
Anybody know the
alphabet that this is?
OK, that's good.
Most of you have not
seen these before.
That's good that you know.
But we'll do this experiment
run on the rest of you.
So here's one
example of a concept.
Call it a tufa if you like.
And I'll just run my mouse
over these other ones.
And you just clap when I
get to the other example
of the same class, OK?
[SOUND OF CLAPS]
OK, very good.
Yeah, people are,
basically, perfect at this.
It doesn't take--
I mean, again, it's
very fast and almost perfect.
And again, you saw me talk a
little about this last time.
Just like with natural
objects, not only
can you learn one of these
concepts from one example
and generalize it
to others, but you
can use that knowledge
in various other ways.
So you can parse these
things into parts.
We think that's part
of what you're doing.
You can generate new examples.
So here are three
different people all
drawing the same character.
And in fact, the whole data
set was generated that way.
You can also make higher
level generalizations,
recombining the parts
into totally new concepts,
the way there's that weird
kind of like unicycle thing
over there, unimotorcycle.
Here, I can show
you, as you'll see
10 characters in a
new alphabet, and you
can make up hypothetical,
if, perhaps,
incorrect examples in it.
Again, I'm just
going to show you
a couple of case
studies of where
this idea of learning as
program synthesis might work.
So the idea here is
that, as you might see,
these are three characters
down on the bottom.
And this is just a
very schematic diagram
of how our model tries to
represent these as simple kinds
of programs.
Think about how you would
draw, say, that character down
to the bottom.
Just try to draw it in midair.
How would you draw that one
in the lower left there?
Are many of you doing
something like this?
Is that what you are doing?
OK, yeah.
So basically,
everyone does that.
And you can describe
that as sort
of having two large
parts or two strokes,
where you pick up your
pen between strokes.
And one of the strokes
has two sub strokes,
where you stop your pen.
And there's a
consistent relationship.
The second stroke has
to begin somewhere
on a particular general
region of the first stroke.
And basically, that's the
model's representation
of concepts-- part, subparts,
and simple relations-- which,
you can see, it might
scale up, arguably,
to more interesting
kinds of natural objects.
And the basic idea is that
you represent that, though,
as a program.
It's a generative program.
It's kind of like
a motor program.
But it's more abstract.
We think that when you
see these characters
and many other concepts,
you represent something
about how you might create it.
But it doesn't mean
it's in your muscles.
You could use other hands.
You could use your toe.
Or you could even just think
about it in your imagination.
So the model, basically,
tries to induce these simple--
think about them as maybe
simple hierarchical plans,
simple action programs.
And it does it by having
a program generating
program that can
itself have parameters
that can be learned from data.
So this right here, this is a
program called GenerateType.
And what that does
is it's a program--
a type means a
character concept,
like each of those three
things is a different type.
This is a program which
generates a program that
generates the actual character.
The second level of program
is called GenerateToken.
That's a program which
draws a particular instance
of a character.
And just like you can draw
many examples of any concept,
you can call that
function many times--
GenerateToken,
GenerateToken, GenerateToken.
So your concept of a character
is a generative function.
And in order to learn
this, you have, basically,
a prior on those programs that
comes from a program generating
program.
That's the GenerateType program.
So there's a lot of details
behind how this works.
But basically, the
model does a kind
of learning to learn up from
a held out unsupervised set
and learns the parameters
of this program generating
program, which
would characterize
how we draw things in
general, what characters look
like in general.
And then, when you see a new
character, like this one,
effectively, what
the model is doing is
it's both parsing this into
its parts, and subparts,
and relations.
But that parsing is, basically,
the program synthesis.
It is pretty much
the same thing.
You're constructing,
you're looking
at that output of some
program and saying, what
would be the best simple
set of parts, and subparts,
and relations that
could draw that?
And then I'm going to
infer the most likely one,
and then use that as a
generalizable template
or program I can then generate
other characters with.
So here, maybe to just
illustrate really concretely,
if you were to see
this character here--
well, here's one
instance of one class.
Here's an instance
of another class.
Again, I have no idea
which alphabet this is.
Now, what about this one?
Is it class 1 or class 2?
What do you think?
1, yeah.
Anybody think it's class 2?
OK.
So how do we know it's class 1?
Well, at the pixel level,
it doesn't look anything
like that.
So this is, again, an
example of some of the issues
that Tommy was talking
about-- a really severe kind
of invariance.
But it's not just translation
or scale invariance,
although it does
have some of that.
But it also has this kind
of interesting within-class
invariance.
It's a rather different shape.
It's been distorted somewhat.
For a program,
there's a powerful way
to capture that where
you can say, well
if you would do something
like the program
for generating this, which
is like one stroke like that
and then these other two things
shown with the red and green,
and here's a program that you
might induce to generate that.
And then the question is,
which of these two programs,
simple hierarchical
motor programs,
is most likely to
generate that character?
Now, it turns out that
it's incredibly unlikely
to generate any character
from one of these programs.
These are the log scores,
the log probabilities.
So this one is like 2
to the negative 758.
And this one is like 2
to the negative 1,880.
I don't know if it's base e.
It's maybe 2 or e, but whatever.
So each of these is very small.
But this one is like
1,000 orders of magnitude
more likely than that one.
And that makes sense, right?
It just is easier
to think intuitively
about generating this
shape from that distortion.
So that's basically
what the system does.
And it's able to do
this remarkable thing
that you were able to do
too-- this one-shot learning
of a concept.
Here's just another
illustration of this.
We show people one
example of a new character
in an alphabet they
don't know and ask them
to pick out the other one.
Everybody see where it is here?
It's not that easy,
but it's doable.
Down here, right.
So people are better
than 95% correct at this.
This is the error rate.
So the error rate
is less than 5%
for humans and also
for this model.
But for a range of more
standard deep learning models,
this one here is, basically,
like an image net or MNIST type
1.
So this is the
kind of model that
was really sort of massive
convolutional classifier.
The best deep learning
one is actually
something for this problem.
It's what's called
a Siamese ConvNet.
And that can do somewhat better.
But it's still more than
twice as bad as people.
So we think this
is one place where,
at least in a hard
classification problem,
you can see that deep learning
still isn't quite there.
Whereas this-- even
the best thing-- this
was a network that was,
basically, specifically worked
out by one of Ruslan's
students for about a year
to solve exactly this
problem on this data set.
And it substantially improved
over a standard deep learning
classifier, which
substantially improved
over a different
deep learning model
that Ruslan and
I both worked on.
So there's definitely been
some improvement here.
And never bet against
deep learning.
I can't guarantee that somebody
sets, spends their PhD.
They could work out something
that could do this well.
But still, it's a case which
still has some room to push,
where, for example,
just a pure pattern
recognition approach might go.
But maybe more
interesting is, again,
going back to all the things
we use our knowledge for, kids
might use our knowledge for.
As we don't just
classify the world.
We understand it.
We generate new things.
We imagine new things.
So here's a place where you
can use your generative program
that none of these networks
do, at least by nature.
Maybe you could think of some
way to get them to do it.
And this is to say,
not just classify,
but to produce,
imagine new examples.
So here's an
illustration of this
where we gave people an example
of one of these new concepts.
And then we said, draw another
example of the same concept.
Don't just copy it.
Make up another
example of the concept.
And what you can see here
is a set of nine examples
that nine different people
did in response to that query.
And then you can also
see on the other side
nine examples of our
program doing that.
Can anybody tell
which is the people
and which is the program?
Let's try this out.
So which is the machine for
this character, the left
or the right?
How many people say the left?
Raise your hand.
How many people say the right?
About 50-50, very good.
How many people say this is
the machine for this one?
How many people say
this is the machine?
May be slight preference there.
How many people say
this is the machine?
Some people really
like the left.
How many people say
that's the machine?
Basically, it's 50/50
for all of them.
Here's the right answer.
I don't know, you could decide
if you were right or not.
I don't know,
Here's another set.
Again, I hope it's clear that
this is not an easy task.
And in fact, people are,
basically, at chance.
We've done a bunch
of studies of this.
And most people just can't tell.
People on average are
about 50% correct.
You basically just can't tell.
So it's an example of
a kind of Turing test
that a certain interesting
program learning
program is solving.
At the level that's
confusable with humans,
this system is able to
learn simple programs
for visual concepts.
And not just classify but use
them to create new things.
You can even create new
things at this higher level
that I mentioned.
So here, the task, which,
again, people and machines
are roughly similar on, is
to be given 10 examples each
of a different concept
in a higher level
concept, like an alphabet,
and then draw new characters
in that alphabet.
And we give people only
a few seconds to do this.
So they don't get too artistic.
But again, you can see that
machine is able to do this.
People are also kind of similar.
So let me say,
that was a success
story, a place for the idea of
learning as program induction
kind of works.
What about something more
like what we're really
most deeply interested in--
children's learning?
Like the ability, for
example, to, say, understand
goal-directed action.
These cases we've
talked a lot about.
Or intuitive physics-- again,
cases we've talked about.
And it's part of
our research program
for this center, something
we'd love all of you guys,
if you're interested,
to help work on.
It's a very big problem.
It's how do you characterize
the knowledge that kids
are learning over the first
few years and the learning
mechanisms that
build it, which we'd
like to think of in
some similar way.
Like could we say there's
some intuitive physics program
and intuitive physics
program learning programs
that are building out knowledge
for these kinds of problems?
And we don't know how to do it.
But again, here are
some of the steps
we've been starting to take.
So this is work that Tomer
did as part of his PhD,
and it's something
that he's continuing
to do with Liz and others
as part of his post-doc.
So we're showing people--
again, it's much like what you
saw from me and from Laura.
We're really interested in
learning from sparse data.
Because all the data
is sparse in a sense.
But in the lab, you push
things to the limit.
So you study really
sparse things,
like one-shot learning
of a visual concept.
Or here, this is like we've
been interested in what can you
learn about the laws
of physics from just
watching that for five seconds.
So we show people
videos like this.
Think of this as like you're
watching hockey pucks on an air
hockey table.
So it's like an overhead view
of some things bouncing around.
And you can see
that they're kind
of Newtonian in some sense.
They bounce off of each other.
Looks like there's some
inertia, inertial collisions.
But you might
notice that there's
some other interesting
things going
on that are not
just F equals m a,
like other interesting
kinds of forces.
And I'll show you other ones.
Tomer made a whole awesome
set of these movies.
Hopefully, you've got some
idea of what's going on there.
Like interesting forces of
attraction, and, repulsion,
different kinds of things.
So here, each of those can
be described as a program.
And here's a program generating
program, if you like.
So the same kind of idea, just
as in the handwritten character
model I showed you.
It's not like it's learning in
a blank slate way from scratch.
It knows about objects,
parts, and subparts.
What it has to learn
is, in this domain
of handwritten
characters, what are
the parts and relations like.
And then for the
particular new thing
you're learning, like this
particular new concept,
what are its particular
parts and relations.
So there's these several
levels of learning
where the big picture of objects
and parts is not learned.
And then the specifics
for this domain
of handwritten characters, the
idea of what strokes look like.
That's learned from sort
of a background set.
And then your ability to do
one-shot learning or learning
from very sparse
data of a new concept
takes all that prior knowledge,
some of which is wired in,
some of which is
previously learned,
and brings it to
bear to generate
a new program very sparsely.
So you have the same
kind of thing here.
We were wiring in,
in a sense, F equals
m a, the most general
laws of physics.
And then we're also wiring
in sort of the possibility
that there could be kinds
of things and forces
that they exert on each
other, as some kinds of things
exert other kinds
of forces on others.
And that there could
be latent properties,
things like mass and friction.
And then what the
model is trying to do
is, basically, to learn about
these particular properties.
What's the mass of
this kind of object?
What's the friction of
this kind of surface?
Which objects exert which
kind of forces on each other?
Is there something like
gravity blowing everything
to the left, or
the right, or down?
What this is showing
here is the same kind
of plots we saw
from me last time.
It's a plot of
people versus model,
based on a whole bunch
of different conditions
of the sort you saw.
People are judging these
different physical properties.
And they're making
greater judgments
of how likely it is,
basically, to have one
of these properties or another.
And there's the model on the
x-axis, people on the y-axis.
And what you can see is
a sort of OK decent fit.
We characterize this experiment
as a kind of a mixed success.
I mean, it's sort
of shocking people
can learn anything at all.
Like how much could you learn
about the laws of physics
from five seconds
of observation?
Well, it's also kind
of shocking that Newton
could learn about the laws of
physics by just looking at,
you know, in the history
of the universe, about five
seconds or less worth of data
that people had collected
for the planets going around.
So it is the nature of both
science and intuitive theory
building that you can get
so much from so little.
But people are not Newton here.
They're just using intuition.
They're making quick responses.
And they're OK.
There's a correlation, but
it's not perfect by any means.
One of the things that
we're working on right
now is looking at,
say, what happens
if you can, unlike, say, Newton,
go in and actually intervene
and push these planets around.
Hopefully you'll do better.
But stay tuned for that.
The basic thing here, though, is
that people can learn something
from this.
But the way our model works is
it's not very satisfying for us
as a view of kind of
program induction or program
construction.
Because we think it just
knows too much or has,
basically, all the
form of the program.
And it's estimating
some parameters.
It's like one of the things
you do as a hacker, as a coder,
is you have your code and
you tune some parameters.
Or you try to decide if this
function is the right one
to use or that one.
And this is doing that.
But nowhere is this like
actually writing new code,
in a sense.
And that's just the
really hard problem
that I wanted to mostly
leave you with and set up
going what we're going to do
for the rest of the afternoon.
Like if you wanted to not
just tune the parameters
and figure out the strength or
existence of different forces,
but actually write the form of
laws, how would you do this?
What's the right
hypothesis space?
So you'd need programs that
don't just generate programs
but actually write the
code of them in a sense.
And what's an
effective algorithm
for searching the space
of these theories?
It's very, very difficult.
I think, Tomer, are you going
to show this figure at all?
Yes, so mostly I'll
leave this to Tomer.
But there's a very
striking contrast
between the nice optimization
landscapes for, say,
neural networks or most
any standard scalable
machine learning
algorithm, whether it's
trained by gradient
descent or convex
optimization, and the kinds
of landscapes for optimization
and search that you have if
you're trying to generate
a space of programs.
If you want to see our early
attempts to try to do something
like learning the
form of a program,
look, for example, at stuff
that Charles Kemp did.
Part of his thesis
that was published
in PNAS a few years ago,
where he tried to generate
or, basically, have--
think of generative
grammars for graphs.
Think about the problem--
so Laura mentioned Darwin.
How did Darwin figure out
something about evolution
without understanding
any of the mechanisms?
Or the more basic problem
of figuring out that species
should be generated by
some kind of branching tree
process versus other kinds.
Remember last time when I
talked about various kinds
of structured
probabilistic models, tree
structures, or spaces, or
chains for threshold reasoning.
So Charles did some
really nice work,
basically trying to use the
idea of a program for generating
graphical models, like there's
a grammar that grows out graphs.
And he showed how
you could take data
drawn from different domains,
like, say, those data sets
you saw before of animals
and their properties.
We spent an hour
on that last time.
So Charles showed how you
could induce not only a tree
structure but the higher level
fact that there is a tree
structure.
Namely, a rule that
generates trees
being the right
abstract principle
to, say, give you the structure
of species in biology,
whereas other rules
would generate
other kinds of structures.
So for example, he took
similar data matrices
for how Supreme
Court judges voted
and was able to
infer a left-right,
liberal-conservative spectrum.
Or data from the proximities
between cities and figure
out a sort of cylinder,
like latitude and longitude
map of the world just from
the distances between cities.
Or take faces and figure
out a low dimensional space
as the right way to
think about faces.
So in some sense,
this was really cool.
We were really excited.
Oh, hey, we have a way to learn
these simple programs which
generate structures, which
themselves generate the data.
It's where that idea
of hierarchical Bayes
meets up with this idea
of program induction
or learning a program.
And it even captured--
OK, this is really the
last slide I'll show.
It even captured
something which captured
all of our imaginations.
We use this phrase "the blessing
of abstraction" to tie back
into one more theme of Laura's,
which is this idea that when
kids are building up
abstract concepts,
there's a sense
in which, unlike,
say, a lot of maybe traditional
machine learning methods
or a lot of traditional
ideas and philosophy
about the origins of
abstract knowledge,
it's not like you just get
the concrete stuff first
and layer on the
more abstract stuff.
There's a sense
often, in children's
learning as in science, in which
the big picture comes in first.
The abstract idea comes
there, and then you
fill in the details.
So for example,
Darwin figured out,
in some sense, the big picture.
He figured out the
idea that there
was some kind of branching
process that generated species
that was random.
Not a nice perfect Linnean
seven-layer hierarchy
but some kind of random
branching process.
And he didn't know
what the mechanisms
were that gave rise to it.
And similarly, Newton
figured out something
about the law of gravitation
and everything else in his laws,
though he didn't know
the mechanisms that
gave rise to gravity.
And he didn't even know g.
He didn't even know the value
of the gravitational constant.
That couldn't be estimated
for 100 years later.
But somehow he was able
to get the abstract form.
And these nice things
that Charles Kemp did
were also able to do that.
So for example, from
very little data,
to figure out that animals
should be generated
by some kind of
a tree structure,
as opposed to, say,
the simpler model
of just a bunch
of flat clusters.
That model was able
to figure that out,
over here on the right,
from just a small fraction
of the data.
And then with all
the rest of the data,
it was able to figure out
the right tree in a sense.
And we called this "the
blessing of abstraction,"
this idea that often, in these
hierarchical program learning
programs, you could
get the high level
idea before you got
the lower level idea
and then fill in the details.
And I still think there's
something fundamentally right
about this idea of
children's learning,
both representationally
and mechanistically.
And that this dynamics
of sometimes getting
the big picture first and using
that as a constraint to fill
in the details is
fundamentally right.
But actually,
understanding how this--
either algorithmically-- how
to search the space of programs
for anything that looks like
an intuitive causal theory
of physics and relate
that to the dynamics
of how children actually learn.
That's the big open question
that I will now hand over
to our other speakers.